on en parle ce matin avec mode Gatel qui
est député de Paris et député MoDem de
Paris bonjour merci d'être avec nous
est-ce qu'on en sait un peu plus
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous retenez
d'ailleurs au fond de cette intervention
de d'Élisabeth est-ce que le plus
important c'est pas finalement qu'elle
dise oui il y aura une réforme quoi
qu'il arrive c'est ce qu'on a entendu ce
matin model oui il y aura une réforme et
c'est indispensable pourquoi c'est un
indispensable c'est parce que on a les
projections à long terme du corps du
Conseil d'orientation des retraites qui
nous le dit ce qu'on savait c'est-à-dire
que la pérennité du système de retraite
donc les pensions de nos retraités n'est
pas assurée à l'avenir or le système de
retraite à la française c'est au
fondement du pacte social et donc il
faut le réformer mais il faut le
réformer en tenant compte des inégalités
qui existent aujourd'hui les petites
retraites les carrières longues la
pénibilité il faut assurer la pérennité
de ce système mais un système juste
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ces
critique
je vous dis tiens finalement tout va
bien il y a rien besoin de changer ben
moi je suis désolé mais pour moi le
système actuel des retraites il est
injuste il est injuste parce que si on a
avancé sur les petites retraites des
agriculteurs et je salue votre président
de groupe lors du précédent mandat on a
toujours des retraites qui sont à un
niveau indécent et il faut faire en
sorte et c'était d'ailleurs la
proposition du Président de la
République de faire en sorte que toutes
les retraites soient à minima à 1000
euros on a le sujet de la pénibilité la
pénibilité on n'arrive pas à l'âge de
départ à la retraite après ces annuités
de la même manière dans le même état
physique quand on a fait des travaux
physiques toute sa vie ou quand on a été
dans un bureau on a le sujet des
carrières longues on a le sujet des
femmes on a le sujet
mais vous allez aggraver
62 ans
la moitié des personnes à 62 ans sont au
chômage et en invalidité première longue
donc vous allez discrimination à l'égard
des femmes
qui doivent s'arrêter pour des questions
de maternité donc c'est une réforme
globale une réforme comme le dit
François Bayou une réforme de société
je vous parle de ce que moi ce à quoi
j'aspire c'est une réforme globale qui
est à la base de notre pacte social
alors savoir ce qu'on va le système le
plus juste possible mais en remettant à
plat un certain nombre de choses pour
garantir la pérennité de nos systèmes de
retraite à l'aise avec l'idée du 49-3
mode Gatel
cette réforme c'est une réforme de
société si on parle de la réforme des
retraites c'est une réforme de société
et nous on considère et François
bayroule arrudis encore hier que ça
signifiait on a assez discussions depuis
ça fait ça fait 30 ans qu'on parle de
réforme des retraites donc c'est pas
nouveau simplement il faut mettre un
certain nombre de constats sur la table
on a bien vu qu'on était pas d'accord
déjà entre nous sur la nécessité ou non
de réformer les retraites moi je
considère qu'il faut une réforme des
retraites et mettre sur la table
l'ensemble des propositions des
organisations syndicales et patronales
prenons le pronom le temps de la
discussion à nouveau c'est une c'est un
enjeu
tellement important
alors le 49-3 sur le budget c'est une
chose le débat sur la région des
retraites sur le débat sur la réforme
des retraites
c'est me semble-t-il nécessaire de
mettre l'ensemble des parties prenantes
autour de la table parce que c'est une
réforme majeure
en Italie on a d'abord une grande
tristesse parce que je ne crois pas que
les extrêmes de tout bord soient de
nature à répondre aux mots que vivent
nos démocraties alors je dois vous dire
Monsieur peu que j'ai pas beaucoup aimé
votre sous-entendu sur la guerre en
Ukraine
c'est pas de la faute de l'Union
européenne ici la guerre en Ukraine et
bien au contraire d'ailleurs l'Union
européenne l'Union européenne était
censée nous protéger et réaliser la paix
et nous avons la guerre sur le continent
oui alors l'Union européenne d'abord ne
comporte pas ni l'Ukraine ni la Russie
par ailleurs n'oublions pas les
responsabilités de chacun la
responsabilité c'est l'invasion russe
sur le territoire ukrainien et l'Union
européenne qui agit comme jamais à la
fois à travers les sanctions et à
travers le la livraison de matériel
militaires à l'Ukraine pour essayer de
faire en sorte que l'intégrité des
frontières de l'Ukraine et les nôtres
soient préservés simplement sur
l'arrivée sur l'arrivée de l'extrême
droite probable au pouvoir à la tête
d'une coalition en Italie moi évidemment
je j'y vois c'est un résultat
démocratique je n'ai pas de évidemment
je ne vais pas me mêler contre ça
simplement on voit bien que face aux
difficultés économiques et sociales que
nous subissons les populismes font leur
beurre là-dessus en revanche je n'ai pas
je n'ai jamais eu le sentiment que
l'extrême droite était une réponse au
mot de nos démocraties